[Music]
Sin City has just added recreational
marijuana to its list of indulgences at
midnight last night medical marijuana
dispensaries in Las Vegas began selling
pot to anyone who can prove they are
over the age of 21 the measured
legalized marijuana was approved by
Nevada voters last November now for the
first time a torrent of 4th of July
tourists will be able to enjoy some high
times but with some restrictions Jamie
yuccas has the story
the midnight launch of legal
recreational marijuana sales prompted
lines at several Las Vegas dispensaries
it's finally you know here it's been a
long fight for us all and we're all glad
can't wait
many pot shops have been gearing up for
the extra business and feeling the
pressure
you have influx of people trying to pick
up and get and secure a product for the
influx of people that are going to be
able to purchase now it's not a bad
thing but it's gonna be interesting to
see how it all plays out although you
can buy a joint for between five and ten
bucks don't even think about lighting up
on the strip while smoking a cigarette
in a casino is fine smoking pot in
public is against the law it comes with
a six hundred dollar fine we are being
inundated by party houses and short term
rentals because the only legal place to
smoke weed is in private residences
homeowners are concerned about party
houses popping up if we're gonna come
here they got the water buy it that's
legal they don't want to use it so let's
fear how to do that Nevada State Senator
tix ager Blum believes the city needs to
create some alternatives people have
come to me about having marijuana but
been breakfast hotels
renting out golf courses ran out of Hope
restaurants there's all kinds of ideas
out there buyers can purchase up to an
ounce of weed at a time which costs
around two hundred dollars but many
believe edibles will be more popular
with tourists because they can be
consumed without attracting attention
but unlike medical marijuana no
prescription is required so there's no
paper trail so what goes on in Vegas is
your business part of the ballot measure
it ensured that
people could purchase cannabis
anonymously and not have to worry about
you know Big Brother paying attention to
what they're doing and while it will
only be neon lights lighting up on the
Vegas strip Nevada joins Washington DC
along with seven other states which will
allow sales of recreational pot it may
appear marijuana has gone mainstream but
it remains illegal under federal law
still in a town famous for pleasure
seekers many wanted to be among the
first to take in its newest legal vice
it's a little bit surreal you know I
can't believe this many people would
show up and support the legalization of
cannabis we're very excited for CBS this
morning Saturday Jamie yuccas Los
Angeles I mean how it all makes sense in
Las Vegas although I'm glad that pot and
slot machines are not coming together
that seems like bad idea in neon lights
you know what I mean yes I know just
what you mean